it's a risk factor uh for early death
and other bad health outcomes in general
and with regard to kovid we were talking
about this as early as like i said april
21st 2020 in our in our ninth livestream
i went back and looked assuming that my
my notes are complete um i i think we
didn't talk about it before then but we
definitely talked about it then
um so
i just before we talk about some of what
is going on with children i want to
review some of what we know about
obesity uh in uh with regards
specifically to covid and in
live stream
number 69 on february 27th of this year
uh we
showed oh he's just showing me the wrong
paper here um actually
zach you can show this
table briefly and then maybe i'll just
pull it back um actually
apologies here's the paper it's a hern
at all uh 2021 called coronavirus
disease 2019 hospitalizations
attributable to cardio metabolic
conditions in the united states a
comparative risk assessment analysis
if i may have my screen back here i
think i
made some
here we go just a couple of there we're
not going to go through the paper in
depth again we talked about this in
episode 69.
um they find and you may show my screen
here if you like zack in the abs from
the abstract as of november this is
published a while ago so this is not up
to date but we see nothing to suggest
that what they've found has been
overturned as of november 18 2020 an
estimated 906 849 cover 19
hospitalizations occurred in u.s adults
of these an estimated 20.5 percent with
95
uncertain you know i'm not going to
focus on the numbers here an estimated
20.5 percent of coveted 19
hospitalizations were attributable to
diabetes mellitus
30.2 to total obesity uh with that is to
say body mass index over 30 kilograms
per
meter squared
there is a relationship between height
yes but meters squared sounds like an
area right i don't think that's what
they mean i think the formula includes
the person's height squared somehow but
yeah okay so what are the clinical
implications of what they have found
having f found the top risks again were
obesity hypertension and diabetes they
say clinicians should educate their
patients who may be at risk and consider
promoting preventative lifestyle
measures such as improved dietary
quality and physical activity to improve
overall cardiometabolic health and
potentially minimize the risk for
chronovirus disease 2019 severity
sounds like a good idea does it not
um and finally there's one more thing
from this paper in the most recent cdc
analysis of available national data
among individuals diagnosed with cover
19
a 35 year old with diabetes hypertension
cardiovascular disease obesity or other
chronic conditions had a similar risk of
cova-19 related hospitalization as a 75
year old with none of these conditions
and a similar risk of copenhagen related
death as a 65 year old with none a
dramatic biologic aging effect of poor
metabolic health on risk of severity of
a viral infection such as covenanting
so again a 35 year old with one of these
prime comorbidities
is in
worse shape
or as similar shape with regard to
covert risk as a 75 year old with none
of those risks it's amazing which is an
extraordinary finding so thank you zach
given the steep aging curve of this
disease yeah because age is
it goes it goes from a trivial disease
for very young healthy people to a
spectacularly dangerous disease well
spectacularly dangerous a very dangerous
disease
to elderly and elderly people exactly
and the fact that um you know of course
of course it's not that simple but
the amount to which
to some degree especially if you are
currently healthy staying healthy is
relatively easy
and if you have one of these conditions
in so far as you can in as much as
possible taking control of your own
health
and getting your weight down getting
your hypertension under control to some
degree
can actually affect outcomes across
across domains and so we have also
talked about however the fact that the
clinical uh suggestions here that health
officials and doctors advise patients to
you know to lose weight and to to
address the health conditions that they
can actually control as opposed to
as opposed to simply relying on external
sources of health which is what the the
single-minded uh public policy on
dealing with covid seems to be
um basically isn't happening now we did
talk in um
[Music]
a couple live streams ago in 107 i guess
about some health
advice that's coming out of florida now
in which they're actually saying go
outside get active eat healthy you know
move your body and it sounds great but
it's literally the only one that i've
found i'm certainly not hearing anything
like this at the federal level
and what we have seen
is i'm going to just revisit since this
is again from our ninth livestream a
piece that we saw in wired and then one
from the l.a times more recently uh that
what is the mainstream media doing with
this kind of actual research results
around comorbidities and covet and how
you can reduce your risk well in
april 17 2020
wired
published a piece called cova19 does not
discriminate by body weight the claim
that those with higher bmis are at
special risk of dying from the
coronavirus is grossly overstated
uh and
here very quickly just zach show my
screen to
to demonstrate that this is this is in
fact what the article uh
what the article looks like
one of the things they said is obesity
appears to be one of the biggest risk
factors related to coven 19
hospitalizations and critical illness
newsweek claimed on tuesday yet this
rhetoric is based on flawed and limited
evidence which only exacerbates the
stigma that larger bodied people already
face in society in our health care
system the stigma is what truly
jeopardizes their health not weight
itself wow in fact it's only more
important to consider in the midst of
this pandemic
the stigma is what jeopardizes their
health and the article ends with this
gem
instead of trumpeting the supposed risks
of high bmi and adding to the already
damaging impact of weight stigma
researchers need to be asking deeper
questions and public health officials
and journalists need to report on the
science in more nuanced and sensitive
ways
as of today december 18th 2021 there is
neither a correction or attraction
anywhere associated with that article
from wired which is from april 2020. and
which point we already knew that obesity
was comorbidity and we still know that
follow the sensitive science
follow the sensitive people and their
feelings there you go yeah wow that's
really fascinating and i must say i do
think that uh you know
bmi is a proxy for something and it's
it's deeply flawed
but
you know all else being equal does bmi
correlate with
risk for covid it clearly does it
clearly does um and so the question is
okay you could add nuance to this right
for one thing bmi is such a crude
measure in its formulation
that you really don't know very much
about you know
whether someone is overweight or how
overweight they are based on the simple
measure because there are body shape
differences
and obviously you know somebody can have
an awful lot of uh you know muscle mass
there's a level at which that can become
a hazard and of itself but basically
there's a lot of variation that isn't
captured in this one measure
but it's a you know it's a decent proxy
and it's in to the you know all of the
sorts of measures that we take
uh erase a certain amount of nuance in
order to discover a pattern and the
point is yes you can also study the
pieces of nuance and you get a
diminishing returns pattern where you
know bmi may explain the lion's share of
the pattern and then you can recover
other things from
uh from different factors but the idea
that a high bmi can reverse
the risk stratification for age
right in coba 19 that's incredible it's
a clear it's a clear pattern right and
the point is it doesn't mean that an
individual's bmi tells you anything
because the individual could be a
bodybuilder or whatever but um but
nonetheless the pattern is there and to
deny it on the basis
um that you know it causes stigma which
is the health concern is obviously
upside down and backwards right and
frankly most individuals
know this you know if
if you're huffing and puffing after
climbing one set of stairs somewhat
slowly
you're probably not in very good health
i mean in fact i don't know why i'm
hedging with probably i don't i don't
know the situation in which if you're if
you're short of breath after climbing
one flight of stairs
i do not know the situation in which you
are in peak health
uh it could be that you just have
something temporary it could be that uh
you climb the stairs too soon after
having run five miles
and that you're not back at baseline but
uh you know we know this and yes there
are people who have you know
who weigh more than what the standard
suggests they should who are healthy of
course there are um but
that is not
there is so much evidence there is so
much evidence that obesity is a risk
factor across
many many health conditions and
specifically for carbon well i want to
push back there because i don't know
what it's like to be 90. it's possible
that a healthy 90 year old might be
huffing and puffing after a single
flight of stairs i just don't i don't
know um so i won't say you know it's
there's no case but yeah the point is
you know if you're
40 50 a single flight of stairs
shouldn't throw you like that into the
extent that it does that's nature's way
of telling you you need to build more
capacity right um so
anyway it's a minor pushback but yeah no
i i i hear that um
let me
there's just another there there are a
lot of these but there's another amazing
piece on obesity and covert from the la
times which was published this year not
that recently may 9th 2021
uh it's called fat shaming bmi and
alienation covet 19 brought new stigma
to large sorry larger sized people no
large sized people
so you can i'm going to read just the
first short six paragraphs of this
and i i do not know how to pronounce the
names here uh crystal bogon cried after
the after the needle went into her arm
not because her first dose of the
modernity vaccine hurt but because
finally being fat actually paid off
the 53 year old was inoculated in the
parking lot of kaiser permanente in san
jose on a rainy friday in march four
days after eligibility in california was
broadened to include people with
underlying conditions
among them a body mass index of 40 or
more 233 pounds for an adult who is 5
feet 4 inches tall
bogon's medical record at kaiser shows
she is morbidly obese as an activist she
prefers the word fat
her experience with medical providers
has been one incident of size stigma
after another she said like the time she
went in with a scratched cornea and was
told to lose weight
she fears being hospitalized with covet
19 and unable to advocate for herself
for that reason i decide you know what
i'm not going to feel guilty about being
vaccinated i'm going to do it she said
and i'm not going to apologize for it
i've been in fear the whole flip in time
staying home avoiding everybody i
couldn't do my job i'm an electrologist
i removed facial hair i couldn't come to
work i couldn't make money
that however is changing thanks to a
viola vaccine a very sharp needle and a
policy switch that allowed women and men
like bogan a chance to be inoculated
before the general public in california
about a month early
it's not every day that we get something
for free because we're fat said bogon
who launched a youtube channel called
fat product review
we'll stop there for now um
go for it well i just wanted to say a
couple things i mean this story is
layer upon layer of
betrayal yes right the idea that we are
going to at this stage
now
champion
obesity obesity
and portray this as the point at which
it pays off is obviously absurd but
let's just say civilization has failed
this person right the epidemic of
obesity is not about people not caring
people don't choose to be obese right
they can't control something and the
thing that they can't control is
obviously in the realm of what we talk
about in our book hypernovelty right
this is not a genetic defect this is
something about our ancient selves
encountering a modern world in which
there are there is a factor or there are
a number of factors that combine to
cause that system to get out of whack
and
we ought to be if you know i mean this
is
uh increasingly um glaring but we have
public health officials that are
apparently willing to turn civilization
absolutely upside down and to withdraw
all sorts of fundamental rights in order
to advance a one-size-fits-all policy
that is clearly not based in science
and yet
there is no interest whatsoever they're
obsessed with our health as long as the
topic is this narrow focus and the
solution in question is the only one
that they allow us to discuss right
they're obsessed with our health in that
case
and provides no agency for us no agency
in fact the point is actually there are
things you can do to protect yourself
from covet and they're specifically not
advising them right there's not advising
us to take vitamin d they're not
advising people hey this would be a
great moment in fact you know what there
is at the moment with respect to getting
your weight under control extra reason
to motivate right there's a disease out
there and it will afflict you worse so
hey if you needed a little extra push in
that direction here it is are they
saying that no they're saying you know
embrace your high bmi right that makes
no sense and some people are saying
talking about high bmi being a risk
factor is itself a form of fat shaming
and that it's not the high bmi it's the
stigma that's making people sick and
no no it's it's not and again as you say
that's not to say that there isn't
stigma and that's not to say that you
know especially especially for people
um who became
fat as children there are there are in
many cases developmental processes which
cannot be undone such that people will
be you know chronically struggling to
get their weight under control and it
really is not
easy for them to the extent that it's
easy for anyone who gains 10 or 20
pounds to lose it it's not the same
problem it is not the same problem this
isn't a simple thing just like bmi is a
flawed and overly simplistic rubric it's
not you know
calories in calories spent it's not that
simple an equation that actually doesn't
work it depends on you know what it is
that you're eating under what conditions
what else you're doing with your life
and also what your history looks like
and you cannot change that what's done
is done
right and of course you know we are
creating the problem you know one of the
the puzzles that we run into with all
sorts of things whether it's
uh the
need for glasses the need for
orthodontia or uh you know a lifelong
battle with with obesity all of these
things are the result of some influence
right an influence that even if we can't
help people who are already afflicted we
can prevent it from afflicting anybody
else right if you figure out why it is
that kids suddenly need orthodontia and
you stop doing that thing to them then
you don't need any more orthodontia for
younger people and you just have to deal
with the people who already have the
issue and the point is
were these people at all interested in
our health they would be focused on
years of life that people are being
robbed of by conditions they would be
focused on quality of life being lost
and there would be some sort of rational
formula that says we should prioritize
this thing because it is robbing people
of the most quality or uh years of life
and we're obviously not doing that you
know in fact even the way we calculate
the harm of covet is absurd right
because the point is that
damage done to young people is vastly
more important than damage down to the
very old just by virtue of the number of
years of theirs that you compromise and
so the idea that you know vaccines good
is
nonsense right because the point is who
you're giving them to and how much they
stand to benefit versus lose it's not
the same parameter and yet we pretend
that it is so that we can get one number
and
um at some level i think we have to call
their bluff they're obviously not
interested in our health i don't know
why they are interested in what they're
interested in it could be that it's
money it could be that it's something
else but for god's sake it's clear that
their obsession their um
the appearance that they are obsessed
with our well-being relative to kovid is
not uh real because if it was they'd be
obsessed with our health on other topics
too and they clearly aren't
[Music]
you